let's start with the hash rate i mean
obviously a just insane year when we
look back uh over 2021 for the hash rate
how do you evaluate what happened yeah
we've talked about it a bunch but just
kind of you know going coming through
all these things that uh you know that
happened in the bitcoin network in 2021
it feels like you know a few years at
least um time time has flown by but also
it's it's felt like a you know quite a
long year with with all this went down
china banning bitcoin uh bitcoin mining
in particular uh in may kind of near
those all-time highs and we saw 50 of
that network cash rate basically shut
off overnight
not really and and it was basically the
biggest attack the bitcoin network has
ever faced maybe besides uh the fork
wars but from a nation-state level um it
was truly unprecedented and uh you know
the bitcoin network went on completely
uh uninterrupted essentially uh
difficulty adjusted downwards uh i think
four or five times in a row um and
seemingly all that hash rate is back
online um and it's you know quite the
recovery almost no one saw it happening
this fast so um you know
quite a unprecedented year but um you
know the resilience of the bitcoin
network cannot be understated
i uh i also see that you've got the
total
total minor revenue here uh and i
actually didn't know this until i saw
that you you sent this chart over that
we started with 30 million dollars a day
on january 1st of 2021 and even though
all the volatility that china banned
like the whole nine yards 45 million
dollars a day 12 29 21. uh talk to us
about this like how important is this to
see that that minor revenue continues to
increase at you know what ends up being
uh a pretty significant rate yeah so
this was uh this is the seven day moving
average i probably should just throw the
the annual average and over the course
of history it probably would have given
a better kind of context but i think the
most remarkable thing about this chart
it looks quite similar to the bitcoin
chart but what you're not taking into
account when you're looking at this in
dollar terms is that is that the having
happens every every four years has
happened uh three times already so that
that block subsidy that miners are
getting first it was 50 bitcoin every
block
uh cut in half to 25 cut in half to 12
and a half and just last may uh i guess
may of 2020 they got cut in half to 6.25
bitcoin every 10 minutes for the block
subsidy so minor revenue continues to be
to go up and to the right uh over the
course of bitcoin's history uh despite
the actual the btc amount going down in
bitcoin terms and so
this is just kind of another chart
that's showing uh how exponential this
network is growing uh and we did see uh
despite all the volatility and the hash
rate dropping and difficulty uh ramping
up going down again and ramping back up
uh minor revenue has been increasing in
dollar terms
it's crazy to see this too and what do
you think is more important is the hash
rate more important there or is it uh
the actual price of bitcoin yeah i mean
it's it's almost like chicken in the egg
because the price of bitcoin going up a
lot of miners can just plug back in
a lot of these miners are just like
almost automated and they take into
account multiple variables such as
the efficiency of their a6 um you know
that's kind of the baseline but really
like power prices in the price of
bitcoin and a lot of these things say
like if you're integrated with the grid
they're going off base load demand so um
if if demand is expected to go up or if
you know there's a surge in say
california or texas then these miners
will shut right off but when the price
of bitcoin goes up um hash price is also
going up which is basically it's minor
revenue divided by hash rate and when
hash rates pump in uh though the value
of all asics is going up and every
bitcoin miner is happy because they're
more profitable in dollar terms yeah it
makes sense all right we got realized
market cap and mvrv ratio explain what
both of these are for folks yeah so we
talked about this a lot um the we had
the market cap which is pretty which is
pretty simple circulating supply times
the price realized cap is uh circulating
supply uh and it's it's the price that
every coin is last moved and we can take
a ratio of that and kind of evaluate how
overheated or cheap bitcoin is on a
relative basis and so we kind of can
visualize these bowl and bear cycles
over over bitcoin's history and you know
if you look at april of 2021 you see
that that ratio was you know really
really high uh and it you know obviously
crashed uh into into may june into that
summer area and now we've kind of with
realized cap continuing to increase
we're we're starting to get to those
pretty cheap levels again but this is
just kind of a broad view of what's
happening in the bitcoin market and i
think it's a you know good long-term
kind of view of what's happening
looks like it's bullish all right
lightning network public channel
capacity seems to have gone on an epic
run but a little bit of a drawback here
is that something to be concerned of and
what do you think about the full year
kind of performance of the public
channel capacity yeah so this is in
dollar terms so it's it's obviously it's
taking into account two variables it's
taking into account um the growth of the
lighting network in bitcoin terms or
that public channel capacity and it's
also taking into account uh the bitcoin
price so we've seen a small pullback in
the actual public channel capacity in
btc terms uh but really that that
pullback there is more associated with
the bitcoin price following about uh 25
30 from the highs but really what we see
2021 was you know a pretty remarkable
year for the lightning network and the
growth of it uh we saw a nation state
adopt bitcoin as legal tender
and and really sort of kind of be
adopted as a transactional medium in a
way that it never has before at a large
scale um so 160 million it seems pretty
small especially with all these numbers
and in the crypto space you know you see
a lot of say d5 protocols with a total
value lock of billions and billions of
dollars the lighting network is is
something completely different and
unique i would i would say in the sense
that it allows this um you know
traditional store of value or
monetary asset that most people just
kind of sit on and huddle uh it allowed
that to be more of a transactional
medium where you could actually buy
coffee with bitcoin for the longest time
it was a meme that you couldn't buy
coffee with bitcoin and it was too cheap
it was too expensive and slow and you
needed something else
well the lightning network actually
fixed that and so i think 2022 we're
going to see that remarkable growth
continue got it now one of my favorite
charts to look at is usually the 0.1 or
0.01 btc bitcoin addresses so these are
people who have a bitcoin address with
at least 0.1 or 0.01 bitcoin uh you've
got here the supply held by entities
with a balance of
0.121 full bitcoin talk to us about this
one yeah i mean it's pretty obvious it's
up and to the right and so
i think this is just one of the things
that uh you can kind of feel when you
when you're talking to people in the
bitcoin space when you're on bitcoin
twitter uh you know see all those
accounts with laser eyes continuing to
grow uh there's just you know a
relentless group of hoglers and stackers
out there all over the world um on
twitter or not uh you know you may they
may be public bitcoiners or not that are
just continuing to stack stats and
increase their proportion of the bitcoin
monetary network and so uh regardless of
price going up down or sideways there's
a cohort of people uh you know
with size would say like michael saylor
but also um just just humbly stacking
away getting to 10 million sats getting
to that that full bitcoin 100 million
satoshis and and they're just you know
continuing to increase their holdings
and so this is kind of that that uh you
know stacker hodler of last resort
mentality and this is you know what is
what stops the price of bitcoin from
going down is is those stackers and
hodlers of last resort